[Music]
i would see children feeling insecure
about who they were because of their
skin color and their complexion but i
will also witness that children
were making fun of each other based off
of their skin color look at her hair
look at her
black children like calling each other
blackie seeing their hair is like nappy
i witnessed this for a long time so i
created this song for the children that
i teach because i wanted to change their
perception of beauty and how they felt
about themselves and i wanted to
encourage them to love themselves
[Music]
i remember growing up and feeling very
insecure about the way i looked
i felt my nose was like not straight
enough it was too flat and i felt my
skin was dark
also when you looked on the television
the images that were portrayed did not
reflect who i was as a black child
after attending college i took a trip to
africa that really made me embrace and
love who i was
i teach at a charter school called helen
y davis leadership academy
we have what's called a girls group one
of the things we talk about is
self-esteem because i saw that many of
the young girls i taught didn't feel
good about themselves and they felt
uncomfortable in their black skin so the
do now question is do you think skin
color determines a person's value or
worth in this society i said no because
i don't think your skin should define
you in any type of way you have to work
hard and not listen to what people say
and keep our mind focused on school so
that we can make it to where we want to
be
i think it's important to use music as a
way to inspire and to transform people's
lives
i vow to make this song for all black
girls to really define beauty for
themselves
in life
there's one thing you should remember
that love of self
is more precious than anything
else i already see a lot of the young
ladies feeling much more confident
they're much more outspoken and they're
much more willing to tell their stories
my black is beautiful my black is
beautiful my black is beautiful it's
what happens when children feel good
about themselves that transfers to all
other aspects of their lives there are
many problems we can solve in this world
and minds is to make sure that black
women feel good about themselves and
black children feel good about
themselves because i think that is the
foundation of all all education
[Music]